let's go to our caller from the oh I
don't know how about the four four three
area code who's calling today from four
four three
hi my name is Rome Baltimore hey how's
it going room leyline loving our
proposals for 2020 however I'm sorry
your phone just cut out when you whose
proposals do you like for 2020 there's a
bit wine Oh Warren okay yeah good yeah
but we can't do anything without you
know the Senate grab not really anything
plans about me taking the Senate some
peers the thing I'm curious to do what
you think about you know I know it's
difficult in terms of the roadmap are we
taking this anything but what I mean I
can't get clean about possibly taking
with me i I don't see any path for
Democrats to take the Senate in 2020 so
here's how I'm thinking about this Rome
2024 the Senate needs to be so here's
what 2020 needs to be expand the
majority in the house take the White
House back from Donald Trump and at
least try not to lose more than a seat
in the Senate because if you look at the
map for 2020 it's tough you also have
Doug Jones a Democrat in Alabama who won
barely against a serial accused child
sex assault her and Roy Moore in the
special election in 2017
you have he's trying to defend the seat
in the very red state of Alabama so I
think that we just need to manage
expectations it's I don't see any path
for Democrats to take the Senate in 2020
that is going to limit what Democrats
are able to get past even if they do
take the White House in November of 2020
but I think of 2020 like as a set up
year to then in 2020 to hopefully be
able to take control back of the Senate
but I think the reason you don't hear a
lot of Democrats talking about taking
the Senate in 2020 because most of them
know it's just not going to happen just
because you're not going to pass
medicare-for-all between January of
twenty twenty-one and
January of 2023 which would be like that
two year period doesn't mean that we
don't still want to vote for the person
who has the right proposal and you never
know what they might be able to
negotiate with Republicans in the Senate
and a house that Democrats control and
then you've got the 2022 election so
it's not null and void I mean listen if
you say to me there's a 5% chance
Medicare for all gets passed no matter
who is in the White House merely because
Democrats aren't going to control the
Senate I still want the person that I
agree with on Medicare for all in the
White House it's not null and void at
all it's just it might be part of a four
or six year process that starts in 2021
question comes up what will be the most
important clinically done thing for
Democrats are we looking at electability
and being in trouble or are we looking
at I don't even think I need to think of
it that way right now we have a primary
we've seen from the polling that we've
seen all of the top four or five
candidates right now we'll have a shot
at beating Trump and it's going to come
down to turnout so right now we just
want to hear from the candidates what
are their policies what are their
positions let's pick the people that we
agree with once we have a general
election candidate then we'll get to
trying to beat Trump which I believe we
can do on turnout we actually the
difference is in terms of the specific
candidates and how they're polling
against Trump there are differences but
ultimately this this could well be a
turnout election so I would not think
about I would not now just start
thinking about electability
all right Rome thank you please let's
see if next time we can get a better
connection because you I love what
you're saying but I just am having a
hard time hearing a lot of it and that's
never good for anybody